last night was the final episode of Game
of Thrones and people just I don't know
what I was fine with it I really likes
it I loved it but a lot of people not
happy how did you feel were you okay
with it no what's wrong with you people
people are such babies I didn't like it
I wrote a different ending 1/8 feel
better do it looks like I said it was
eight seasons of a show it's like you
stayed at someone's house and they
cooked you delicious food the entire
week and the last night they decide to
order pizza and you're like yeah I liked
it I really thought I have a big fan of
the show I really enjoyed it I'm gonna
go on record saying and I thought it was
they wrapped it up very nicely but
watching all this backlash
I mean USA Today was railing against it
right yeah it was the angriest pie chart
I've ever seen
thank you thank you thank you very much
thank you
no a bit but I was watching that like
people get really up or upset with Game
of Thrones where the greatest shows of
all time so that's why I'm happy I've
put a lot of thought into how our show
is gonna end it's going to be season 48
oh boy yeah season 48 yeah I'll be but
it's gonna be great
I'm gonna burn the whole set down and
then I then I'm gonna marry my aunt
Louise Andy you're gonna sail away to
Catalina
I am yeah I am on my gurney just gonna
be a shot of you sailing on a Viking
ship that's a Catalina for no reason
people could be like that's soft